hello folks welcome to
rational science the only site on the
internet that does physics
rationally
today we're going to be talking about
new mana
what in the world is new men on
anyways uh the
subject matter is very much related to
the
flat earthers
back people on both sides of the issue
flatlanders as well as those who oppose
them
should become acquainted with um
new mena okay
and so today we're going to be starting
with the flat earthers then we're going
to continue with pneumonia we're going
to go into that subject from the flat
earthers and then from there we're going
to go into um
tie some loose ends on knowledge
and then followed by our science critic
uh made a video
of uh the scientific method of
criticizing a scientific method and
we're gonna address
uh specifically the issue of what is
an explanation versus what is a
description
and then we're gonna
open the floor up for um questions of
people who ask questions since last time
so let's get on with the flat earthers
and this is where i'm going to start it
i'm going to start by showing what i
think of flat earthers
okay
i think they're very ignorant people
and actually very stupid and i don't do
not apologize uh it's i'm
trying not to offend them it's just a
fact uh these people have very little
understanding of physics and
their reasoning abilities are even worse
uh now i am on record okay i mean i i
i'm on record saying that the um
flatlanders the uh
flat earthers okay
uh these are uh people who are still
as
uneducated as they are
they are far smarter they're like two
notches above the mathematicians okay
the mathematicians
uh fare a lot worse than they do
and why do i say that well uh
you know the flat earthers are ignorant
people because they never went to school
that's that's their problem the
mathematicians on the other hand the
mathematical physicists so-called
physicists
you know they've gone to at least 10
years of schooling to get their phds
and then they come out
talking nonsense
they talk about big bang creationism
which they later deny they talk about
black holes they talk about zero
dimensional singularities
they talk about dark energy whatever
that is
they say it's a measure of their
ignorance
and it's like
what is it like 70 so yeah i think that
really shows a little bit uh it's a good
number to put to the intelligence and
the ignorance of the mathematicians now
they tell you that a particle can be at
two places at once and that they can
time travel and that
time dilates and who knows what other
nonsense that they learned by wrote
in college so yeah i have very little
respect for the mathematicians and in
that sense i put the flat earthers a
little bit above uh mathematicians okay
so that's my starting point um
why do i start on the flat uh earthers
uh there uh the other thing we should
mention about the
uh
flat lenders versus the math magicians
is that the mathematicians they don't
believe the earth is flat
they believe the universe
is flat okay so
yeah forget about the earth being flat
anyways um we started or we let uh
laid off last time uh we abandoned at
the point where
i showed how a balloon moves forward in
a car when the car accelerates
and that's kind of en counterintuitive
because you would think that you know
when
anything accelerates like a car a truck
a train whatever you would think things
go backwards turns out with a balloon
it's the other way around okay it looks
more or less like this okay here it is
uh
give it a second here
so the car accelerates and the balloon
goes forward
and that kind of makes you wonder uh why
is that the case
you know
[Music]
what's going on is is this some
uh fancy trick
it really seems counterintuitive right
okay and we covered that last time and
then uh here
uh together with that uh idea you find
that if you move uh water jug
you know
forward any bubble of air that's you
know on the surface will also move
forward and again that gives you an idea
that what's happening is the water moves
backwards
and because it moves backwards it's got
more density than the uh air so the air
moves forward okay it's got like more
strength than the air okay the water the
liquids essentially drive the air away
okay and it looks more or less like this
as soon as the car accelerates okay
you can see the water goes back and the
bubble of air goes forward
okay so the bubble of air goes in the in
in a counter-intuitive direction you
would think that everything goes
backwards and here they're showing that
it doesn't and that's more or less the
case with air inside the car as well why
it pushes
a balloon forward you know the air
allegedly moves backwards and because of
that the balloon moves forward okay so
this is
the explanation okay
and so i asked a million dollar question
and
i'm a little disappointed with some of
the answers that i got from the flat
earthers okay and again uh they're not
very smart people
uh
and so let me show you what the problem
is what the question is
and it takes a long time for these
people to understand the question
so i'm going to insist one more time see
if maybe one flat earth or another
can
understand the question i just want them
to understand the question forget about
answering it now
okay and so here's the question okay
you're you're on a subway we're on a
train whatever and you're hanging on
right
suddenly the subway moves forward okay
you feel that you go backwards okay
you're you're you know something for
some reason you move backwards okay
and there you can see it the
the
second figure the one in the middle
moving backwards
and if it accelerates even further you
move even further back
okay so uh
that's our experience okay and the
question is why do we move backwards
that's the million dollar question
you're standing still in the subway
subway accelerates you move backwards
why do you move backwards this is the
million dollar question okay
and you'll hear some of the answers
these people gave to this
question okay i call it a simple
question for other people it's not that
simple okay
and here's a
dynamic version of something like that
you can see the car accelerates
and the girls these two girls just fall
off the truck
why what's pulling on them
okay
that's the question
and people say well it's inertia well
that that's not an answer see iner says
what we're trying to explain
in other words uh we call this effect
inertia just like we call uh gravity and
effect we need the explanation for
inertia
and you can't use concepts such as mass
you can't say field you can't say wave
you can't say density
you can't use concepts you have to tell
me what physical object is in touch with
the bodies of the girls that forces them
down that forces them uh in other words
that creates that inertia effect okay so
that's the the million dollar question
okay what physical entity is in contact
with girls
if you say there's nothing in contact
with the girls
which is what uh most people would like
to answer
um then you're doing this by black magic
you're saying that there's absolutely
nothing in contact with them and yet
they are pulled off the truck
that you're you're saying that inertia
works by magic
that's what you're saying in effect
okay let me repeat that when the subway
accelerates you move backwards why do
you move backwards what's pushing or
pulling on you
in the opposite direction
of the subway of the
acceleration of the subway
and you say nothing is pushing nothing
is pulling on me
then you're doing that effect
known as inertia with black magic
okay that's the issue
okay so uh what did one person reply
well he said the phone he says
talking about the airplane because i i
used the airplane
example which was a bad example for me
to use really because these people are
not smart enough to understand what i
was talking about
you know when you get on the airplane
they're already seated
that's when the airplane starts it goes
up in the air starts
going at a constant rate more or less
and at that time you can
stand up go to the bathroom you know go
to the front of the airplane you can do
whatever you want
because you're traveling at the same
speed as the airplane
the issue is here what happens when the
airplane accelerates what happens to you
okay hopefully it throws you to the back
of the plane but they didn't understand
that so
because they didn't understand that they
didn't understand uh they didn't answer
the question so this all says because
yes we are in contact with a plane floor
however we are not attached okay
the plane seats do not move because they
are attached not just in contact so the
answer to your questions is merely
structure
that's that's the answer to my question
structure that's why you
now when the airplane goes forward
uh you stay in place because you're part
of the structure
that's what they're saying and again
he's talking about uh constant
acceleration or constant
speed
that's not what i was talking about i
was i was saying what if it accelerates
okay so again he didn't understand the
question you can glue your shoes to the
plain floor and you will feel like you
are moving back but you are kept in
place as you are
a part of the structure
okay uh he probably uh
had a lot of help
to figure all that out
yeah uh incredible the answer i got from
him and i think same fellow i think he
uh
just put this up there he says horses go
ahead and you the driver lurches back
until the wagon which is tied to the
horses pulls you forward
so you say giddy up horses run you go to
the back
and then once the you hit the back of
the seat now because the whole carriage
is moving forward takes you with it
my god i think uh this guy deserves a
nobel prize for discovering that uh i
hope he did it all by himself didn't
need any help okay another fella tries
to answer the question another flat
earther
nothing is pushing or pulling on me
backwards in a plane uh-huh my body will
move with the plane yeah of course if
you're traveling at a constant speed yes
but see again they don't understand that
if your mass of your body is at rest it
will go with the airplane's direction
okay
when the airplane accelerates it's the
mass of the plane that makes the object
inside it move the
well
mr the
mass is not a physical object so you
cannot say mass does this and mass does
that
and it's interesting that all these flat
earthers they go to some of them go to
high school you know they make it that
far
and they learn all these concepts like
mass and force and energy
in high school you don't learn them in
elementary school but yeah you do learn
them in high school physics
and so they use
the word mass which comes from
mathematical physics
okay
and then they criticize mathematical
physics even though they use the same
language that mathematical physics fed
them
and that's where the problem is because
mathematical physics is nonsense it's uh
just math has nothing to do with physics
okay
and these people are trying to explain
something like mathematicians try to
explain something and you cannot use the
concepts the abstract mathematical
quantitative concepts of math to explain
mechanisms of physics
which is what the entire planet out
there is doing today they're using words
like field and wave and energy and
what
mass
force you know charge
all these are concepts they're
quantitative concepts they have nothing
to do in physics in physics you have to
identify the physical object that is
doing the the
pushing or pulling okay
like you know if a horse is pulling on
you
you say well
why was i pulled well because it was a
horse you can't say it was a concept
called force
okay you can't say that it was uh energy
can't say it was a field no such monster
you gotta say it was a horse
and uh and so on you know and here the
this law says it's the mass
so he thinks he answered the question
not even by a long shot okay
but then he says once my body does reach
the back of the plane
i thought he says it travels uh at the
same you know travels with the plane at
first he says nothing is pushing
or or pulling me backwards in a plane my
body will move with the plane now he
says once my body does reach the back of
the plane this is how these people talk
they just talk in circles then we'll
also start to move with the plane again
as you can't leave the plane through its
solid body
poor soul
bless this whole
anyways uh yeah these are the kinds of
answers that they give they don't
understand the question they use
concepts of math to try to explain a
mechanism
and they thought they answered the
question it was mass that's what it was
and again you know mass
uh in
mathematical physics has
two um
definitions or two general notions one
is quantity of matter and the other one
is weight okay now the mathematicians
never use the quantity of matter they
always use weight so weight and mass are
always synonyms because masses always
weighed and they give it to you in
kilograms
quantity of matter they would have to
say you know that the
bag of marbles has one trillion atoms
and they would specify it in terms of
atoms they would say
the mass of this bag is one trillion
atoms that that they could do
they never do that
they always say the mass of this bag is
one kilogram or one pound or whatever so
they always give you the weight
so in mathematical physics weight and
mass are indistinguishable
and
the only time they try to change this is
that explain that you know if you take
that bag of marbles to the moon
uh its weight
changes but its mass remains the same
and the answer is no though the mass
did the mass change as much as the
weight because we determine mass not by
counting atoms but by weighing so when
you weigh it on the moon that's the mass
of the bag of marbles and until they
count atoms and they uh
express
their uh
masses
in terms of quantity of atoms
they're not going to be doing mass the
physic the
mass of physics which would be related
to physics as long as they use weight a
measurement instead of counting okay one
thing is counting
atoms the other one is just weighing and
giving you a measurement well as long as
they use measurement they're doing
mathematics they're not doing physics at
all
so yeah you can't use the word mass to
explain anything anyways even whether
you use the weight or the quantity of
matter notions of mass
okay um here we have another fella and i
said what causes the air to accumulate
in the rear of the car and the file says
the motion of the container meaning the
car right is what causes the air
displacement inside it causing the air
to move
all he said is
the air moves yeah i know the air moves
we're trying to find out why the air
moves to the back of the car why doesn't
the air move together with the car why
does the density become greater in the
back of the car that's the million
dollar question okay
something came in contact with each
molecule each atom that comprises the
air
okay something is in contact with each
atom
and so when the car moves forward the
air is left behind
otherwise why would the air move
backwards how does the air know that
it's got to move backwards okay
and
this all says well you know i guess he
would say is that the back of the car is
pushing i guess that's what he's
thinking pushing the air
in the back of the car
and and the question here is why does
the whole block of air move forward why
does all the air suddenly moved to the
back of the car he still hasn't answered
that question he won't answer it until
he identifies the physical object that
is in charge in in contact with each
atom with each molecule okay
and here uh he contradicts himself he
says there the motion of the container
is what causes the air displacement
inside it causing the air to move the
solidity of the car container again is
causing it to accumulate in the back of
it again he hasn't
explained it he just says it is so okay
and that's not the question we ask we
ask what is the cause okay and here and
then he says no air molecule is pulled
anywhere it merely falls back down to
where it came from
so uh flat earthers have this idea that
things that fall
have been raised
to begin with this is their logic if you
can call it logic okay
and uh there's uh
another fellow that also says something
um along the same lines but the point
here is that these these folks are
saying you know that uh
before something falls it must rise okay
that's essentially what they're saying
but he this fellow has not explained uh
what causes the air molecules to go to
the back of the
car okay the only way he can explain
that is if he tells us what is in
contact with each
molecule each uh atom that comprises the
air then he would be able to explain it
but to say that it that it does that it
just goes to the back of the car because
the
[Music]
container somehow the motion of the
container he hasn't explained it
oh you know
what is he saying the motion of the
container pushes all the particles to
the back
is that what he's saying
so again yeah you have to tell me what
pushes that last molecule that's close
to your mouth right what pushes it back
to the to the back of the room
that's what he's got to explain okay
and um where did he get this stuff well
they get this stuff from mr galileo some
people say that it was newton but no
newton did not come up with the laws of
motion they were there before he was
born okay
and so this is the galilean so-called
law of inertia again
ridiculous notions that the
mathematicians have that they call
everything a law
in physics we have no laws it's in in
mathematics that they have laws i don't
know who
enacted them who uh legislated them
maybe god i don't know but uh
this is uh the short version a body will
remain at rest unless it is acted upon
by a force
force
uh maybe he met the horse
see a horse
uh can act upon an object like a
carriage there
but not a force there's no physical
object called force so you cannot say a
force does this a force does that okay
not in physics you cannot cut corners
and say well i'm going to
use euphemisms or figures of speech no
you can't you got to be literal so so
when you say when you look at this you
say it was the horse
that pulled on the on the uh
on the carriage on the uh buggy okay
that you can say but you can't see a
force pulled on the buggy okay and so
again uh mathematicians invented these
words and then they uh
extrapolated them onto physics now when
you come into physics you have to put a
physical object there you can't say the
force did it the energy did it the mass
did it
the charge did it you can't use any
concepts
mathematical concept quantitative
concept you have to use physical objects
you got to tell me what physical object
move this and move that
okay that's the issue
okay so uh galileo uh
did not figure it out again all these
people talk about force and other
concepts and that's when they screwed up
because they're doing math they're not
doing physics okay so let's distinguish
those two
okay so um
a lot of these people um
they harp on experiments they want to do
experiments so let's do an experiment
i mean they all want to do experiment
not only the flat earthers the electric
universe uh john chappelle group um the
establishment everybody talks about
experiments that's what they inherited
from the 17th century so-called
scientific revolution okay so let's do
an experiment
and it's known as newton's bucket okay
we're going to try to figure out
if there is
something
a physical entity okay in contact with
the air inside a car
okay
is that possible or is it that
uh we're all crazy we're just saying
that ear just
uh what was it uh the container hit the
the air and that's why it accumulated
no no we have to uh identify something
and newton's bucket is a good experiment
for all those flat earthers to become
acquainted with okay
and let's go through it real quick so
they learned something maybe here it is
okay here's newton's bucket okay we have
we fill a bucket with water and we hang
it from a rope okay
now we're going to torque the rope as
much as we can
and then we let go
as soon as we let go the water
momentarily while the pale
the
bucket spins right the water initially
stays flat at the surface stays flat but
as the bucket spins more and more what
you get is this concavity you have
concave water the water rises at the
edges and sinks in the center of the
bucket okay and when uh the rope stops
spinning the or twerking when the bucket
stops the water is still
twirling around
and uh with that concave uh
surface okay so this is uh newton's uh
bucket experiment he did it in those
days uh
uh
i think 1687 somewhere around there
maybe
anyways this is the the experiment okay
you you troll a bucket and something
which is not the bucket okay by the way
and i'm not going to go through all that
you can look it up uh something outside
of the bucket in fact outside of the
earth
is pulling on that water
let me repeat that for all flat earthers
out there something outside the earth
is pulling on the water on the molecules
of water
okay
now this is where it gets interesting
because uh flat earthers say well how do
you know that and blah blah blah and
they start you know getting all excited
okay so let's go step by step and show
the
flat earthers uh how much intelligence
they really have okay
so here was uh newton's version of what
pulled on the water
uh at the edges of the
uh pail okay and why
form that uh concave surface okay
um uh well first of all let me show you
this is uh
again you see the skater
and uh skater when a skater twirls
uh her arms are being pulled by
something
okay
and the question is what is pulling on
her arms
she feels her arms stretching outwards
and you don't have to take my word for
it you can go and talk to one of these
skaters and they'll tell you that when
they spin their arms are like being
pulled
somewhere
and hopefully it's not the air around
her that's not pulling on her arms so
what you have to tell me is what is
pulling on her arms and this is the same
situation as the air inside the car this
is exactly the same situation as those
girls who were dropped out of the
wagon there they fell on the floor
because the
car accelerated so all these are the
same situation something is pulling on
matter here on earth and uh newton was
saying that it was and in fact all the
mathematicians out there in this uh
are saying that it's something outside
the earth and for once they got this one
right they just don't know what
it is that's pulling from outside the
earth okay
so what's newton's version here it is
newton says it's space okay
he said that when that bucket twirls
it twirls with respect to space there is
an absolute space out there and
everything gauges its motion with
respect to space
that's what that's uh that was his
version of it
uh leibniz uh did not agree with him but
he had no reply to that he couldn't
figure it out either a mathematician
from uh germany okay a couple centuries
later we have another file come in and
his name was ernst mach and he came up
with the uh notion that it's not space
but mass
okay he was talking about the mass of
the stars
and again now these people talk about
mass but mass is not a physical object
you cannot say mass pulls on water okay
you cannot say gravity pulls on water
those are irrational statements okay
and uh so
again one of the things you got to keep
in mind is that you can't just keep
putting concepts there and uh you know
uh hopefully getting by with just a
concept and saying uh you know that you
have this invisible mathematical concept
quantitative it's just a quantity with a
number a number with a
with a unit
and that's pulling on on the pale that's
pulling on the water inside the pail
so this is the problem and so they
summarize it uh as this essentially
mock's principle
created by einstein who gave him credit
for it
he said the paradox of mass there
influences inertia here where's there
there is outside the universe uh he said
it was the stars that
pull somehow okay from a distance action
at a distance somehow pull
on the molecules of water
okay do we have that
and i should have
brought what i showed several times
already and that's um
richard muller professor at berkeley and
he said every atom
uh in your body is being pulled
by every atom on earth okay
so we have all these uh notions out
there here's uh einstein's version
of um
of
what is pulling on you
he in his case it's he says it's warped
time okay
and nasa said they proved it with uh
experiment no or project known as
gravity probe b
they proved frame dragging they say that
the earth drags space around itself this
is the nonsense with which all these
phds
at nasa houston probably you know
came up with warp time so this is what
all these people have come up with in
other words to this day we have no
answer to the question
they have a partial answer that's uh
the universe all the stars somehow are
pulling on us they're in contact with us
somehow
and the way the mathematician's answer
is well it's mass it's gravity but those
are concepts you can't say gravity pulls
on you gravity is what you're trying to
explain
you can't say inertia pulls on you
inherits what you're trying to explain
and you can't say mass pulls on you mass
is what you're trying to explain
why does mass
you know increase its speed right
acceleration as it falls towards the
center of the earth
okay and you can
do that on your own you can take a
bowling ball and wait on top of mount
everest or a high point somewhere wait
at the
low point uh sea level whatever and
you'll find that there's a difference in
weight very small one if you do it at
the same place
more or less you know up down
and you'll find that there's a small
difference in weight okay
and so the acceleration is
greater
as you
reach the center of the earth so what
you have to explain what is pulling on
you now if you say it's push okay fine
explain it with push but you got to
explain but in order to explain you need
to identify the physical object that is
pushing or pulling on you just like you
would explain how you're pulling on a
donkey
same thing you got to explain
what is pull pulling or pushing on
whatever that's causing you know these
accelerations
and again if the um
you have the skater moving around right
the more she spins the more her arms are
being pulled outwards why are they being
pulled outwards what's pulling on them
okay that's what you gotta answer and in
order to answer that you have to
identify the physical object that is in
contact with her hands her arms her body
okay
mathematicians say it's something
outside the earth they never figured it
out
some say it's space some say it's the
mass of the stars which is more or less
the idea they have today and then um
which is mac's principle essentially and
then you have aine and einstein said
it's uh warp time
so that's state-of-the-art explanation
for you of
inertia
okay um
moving on more or less the same issue we
have gravity okay we had inertia just a
minute ago so now let's do a little bit
of gravity
and here uh file says the cause the
pencil drops you know you let go of the
pencil okay my famous experiment you let
go with a pencil and it falls down okay
and so what the flat earthers all say it
says well the reason it falls is because
you pushed it up
this is their logic if you can call it
logic so i pushed it up right pushed it
up and now because there's nothing to
stop it that's why it falls down
that's their answer okay so
they haven't answered anything because i
need to know what's in contact with a
pencil
okay
but let's address that first issue so
the cause of pencil drops is the absence
of matter beneath it okay great the
object will fall down until it meets a
more dense medium that resists it not
that hard uh
poor fell he must have worked all night
to come up with that answer okay i i
know it's hard for them you picked it up
you dropped it you observed the effect
of your own cause so the cause see i
dropped it i didn't push it down i just
let go see let me make sure we
understand i'm not going to push it down
in fact i can push it upwards uh and
it'll fall down anyway see it still
falls down whether i push it up or down
so it's not that i pushed it down okay i
want to make sure that people understand
it i just let go of it and it falls so
no i'm not i i'm not the cause of why it
goes down
okay so no he
mis
answered it
he didn't answer it at all but you know
we have stuff like
asteroids do you believe in asteroids
flat earthers
do you believe in meteorites you can see
them every day they fall on earth
there's all kinds of debris falling on
the earth
from outside the earth we didn't throw
that debris out there and wait for it to
come down we don't throw meteorites out
there and then say okay now it's going
to fall
meteorites come from heaven god i don't
know i don't care but they don't come
from the earth they come from outside
the earth fall on the earth
no one pushed it upwards
okay
and so the question is why do they fall
to earth
what's causing
those meteorites those stones right
to fall to earth that's the million
dollar question for you okay so don't
tell me that i lifted the pencil
and that's why it fell
because i didn't lift the meteorite for
it to fall okay we got that
very simple stuff uh well for normal
people okay but maybe you can get past
that and another foul says
more or less the same thing
show us how a spoon or bowling ball can
fall without it being lifted up first
[Laughter]
you don't seem to understand that
most objects just don't float in mid-air
or fall upwards after being lifted and
then released
and again uh
meteorites don't talk about stuff that
uh you're familiar with talk about stuff
that you're not as familiar with
apparently which are meteorites uh
asteroids you know uh here's uh let me
show you
a list here
uh impromptu list that i've got and
that's um the first one says
chunk of rock falling downhill
now you can argue that um in in that
case uh maybe the mountain pushed it up
originally because you know the mountain
grew
uh over time
right
uh there are all kinds of uh tectonic uh
movements
and so they tend to push mountains
upwards you know at least that's the
theory
and so the the question is um you know
you could argue that the rock was pushed
up originally
fine uh bert lane and egan asked okay
again we have the situation where the
bird
she she was probably not pregnant
uh when she went up there but you could
say that
the egg was manufactured in her body and
so whatever she had in her body she took
up to the nest to begin with before the
egg could drop to the floor so again uh
you can argue that right
um rain snow
uh you know fog same thing uh you could
argue that there are you know these um
hot and cold air that mix up there so
you could argue that the air went up
first before it came down as rain or fog
okay
but here we have other situations like
the air itself that covers the earth
right
we didn't lift that
okay
and so the question is why uh why does
the air uh fall
because there's air that falls and the
question is did that air first rise
is that what you're saying that there
are uh air currents that took it up
well you know you have stratosphere you
know you can have that air up there and
some of that air trickles down
eventually some of those atoms some of
those molecules
okay and so the question is does air
uh fall and the did we put the air up
there
how about the moon you know uh
especially for uh flat earthers you know
the moon uh
uh when it rolls around the
the flat earth as moon and the sun by
the way um does it roll around the flat
earth like they say and they're just
these discs what does that fall
did we put the moon up there also we
raised the moon up there before it fell
and why doesn't it fall
you know please tell me why okay what
causes it to go around why doesn't it
fall okay uh you would think that it
would fall right
what is it a balloon
oh it's not you don't believe in
spherical balloons maybe it's a flat
balloon a pancake balloon
um and again asteroids and comets
meteorites they fall to earth and uh or
to any object and we never put them up
there okay so to say that you know
objects must be first
pushed up before they fall down
that's a non
not answer okay we don't need to put
anything up for it to fall okay
uh file says along the same lines and
this all goes to what we're going to be
talking about today which is numina okay
and here we see this fella says yes we
have a flat moon
these guys are real
um uh use your eyes not your mind well
obviously you haven't used your mind
very much okay
i grant that
you are telling us that there is
something between the magnets we can't
see
exactly i'm saying exactly that i'm
saying there's something between these
two magnets the two run ones okay the
two run ones there
and they stick together and there's
something here we can't see but i can
already feel it pulling and
it's taking it out of my hand and it's
not that i feel something pushing from
the outside it's something from within
okay between the magnets so yeah there's
something there
and you might say
uh
well let's continue he says you are
stating something is there without
demonstrating this
how is that not black magic
what's the other way around if you tell
me that there is nothing
between these two magnets
okay
because you can't see or touch them
which is what all these people want
experiments of some kind experiments
meaning
sight and hands you know
sight and touch uh eyes and hands right
that's what they're looking at they're
saying let's go to the lab and see if we
can see what's in there
and of course they're not going to see
anything because again whatever's in
here is invisible and intangible okay
we can't touch it with our hands at
least we can touch it with iron filings
but
uh we can't interview the iron filing
and find out what what it touched that's
the problem okay we can't touch it and
for sure we can't see it
but if you say that there's nothing
there
then you're saying this happens by black
magic
it just happens no explanation
whatsoever
no mechanism no cause
it just happens it's uh one is pulling
on the other end because you can't see
anything there you say well there's
nothing there
okay and yeah that's gonna
take us to the subject matter today okay
but uh so let's um
let's uh just rub it in what the
question
we need to answer flat earthers need to
answer these questions here you are in
the subway okay
somebody moves forward you are
physically compelled backwards
what is pulling on you why don't you
travel together with the accelera why
don't you accelerate together with the
subway or the train or whatever or the
bus
why does
the bus
go and leave you behind what's holding
on to you
what's pulling on you what's pushing on
you something is holding on to you okay
like that fella said if you're if you're
stuck to the ground you would be moving
with the with the vehicle
but since we're not stuck to the ground
obviously you move backwards i mean
that's our experience right the question
why do you move backwards
okay you say well because the other guy
moved forward yeah but you could
are you standing still is that what
you're saying
okay what's holding you there
why don't you move
with a car even though you're not
attached to the car
i mean you should be able to move with
the car like like
what's why is there a difference between
being attached and not being attached
that's the question okay so you got to
tell me what's holding on to you or
what's pushing or pulling on you
what invisible intangible entity is in
contact with your body that uh compels
you to
you know be pulled backwards when the
vehicle accelerates that's the million
dollar question
okay and to say well it's uh density
it's uh
inertia it's gravity you know we need
that's what we're trying to find out
what is gravity what is inertia what is
mass that's the question okay that's the
ultimate part of the question and the
only way you're going to answer is
identifying the invisible intangible
objects that mother nature uses
okay
here we have
well it says someone says there are
infamous
flat earther who fully believe the moon
landings and iss
uh i don't think so now these people are
dumber than
normal
flat earthers okay they're even dumber
because uh if if
they believe that we went to the moon
and if they believe that we have the iss
rolling around there well uh you know we
have satellites out there and
this is how many satellites we have out
there okay
uh 7400 okay individual satellites in
space at the end of april 2021.
so if we have these many satellites from
different countries
any one of them can take a picture of
the earth from far away or from a
certain distance and tell you that the
earth is spherical that's got a
curved border
and you know people say well how do you
believe that why do you believe that
it's got a curved uh
horizon et cetera et cetera
you're saying all these satellites
different countries they're all
in cahoots and they're all trying to
fool you
oh man
uh you know if i were you i'd watch my
shadow every day you know who knows
maybe they're after you you know
no
any satellite from any country that's
out there i mean you have japan you have
so many countries that send satellites
up there any one of them can take a
picture of the earth in fact you have
google earth
and hopefully you see it roundish
you know uh around the surface
if if the if with so many satellites out
there uh to say that all of these are
hoaxes that all the pictures that
they've taken for example the iss
rolling around the earth shows always a
curvature if you say that's a hoax well
where did you get that why do you think
it's a hoax
all countries are hoaxing you
you know and again uh
yeah you must be scared of your own
shadow then
okay and uh so
someone gave me a good uh response uh
for
what i can consider now a definition of
a flat earther says by id
uninitiated i mean people who believe in
nothing but what they can grasp in their
hands
who will not allow that action or
anything invisible to have real
existence
that's more or less uh summarizes the
flat earther flat earther does not
believe in what we're going to call
today
numina and we'll find out what that is
all about but essentially
flat earther only wants experiments and
what's anything that they can see and
touch
that's how prehistoric they are they say
that's that's all i can
put my uh
finger on and say this is true
and anything else is just a lie a hoax
uh by the intelligence agencies you know
so they don't want to believe anything
other than that and so if they can't see
it and they can't touch it
uh it doesn't exist that's essentially
what it comes out to and again it's
because they have the wrong definitions
irrational definitions the c touch
criteria for object the secret touch
criteria for exist in existence
and those are not the definitions of
object those are not the definitions of
exist
that's where the problem is
so uh what does a
flatlander want well he wants uh
he he wants proof
so the definition that you just
saw is
very specific for them it's it's right
on the money we want science based on
our human senses
except common sense okay uh
all other senses they they think it's
it's all about see and touch
especially those two smell which is
touch hearing which is also touch you
know uh all those are touch
you have to have some contact and but
essentially a c and touch
and so they they don't want to get away
from that and it's like their world is
so small
you know
uh that you ask them um
uh is a table an object
yeah why is it an object because i can
see it and i can touch it
uh-huh it's a chair an object yeah why
because i can see it and touching tree i
can see and touch it rock i can see and
touch it so is the rock that's on the
other side of the planet that you cannot
see or touch
is that an object does that exist
okay so that's the issue
because if you're going to do everything
by sea and touch the moon does not exist
for the blind man because he can't see
it and air must not exist for you
because you can't see it
you say well i can touch it
yeah but you can't see it what are you
touching please draw for me what you're
touching that invisible stuff that
you're you know you know it touches your
hand that's what we want to find out
what it is what is air is it a ghost is
a spirit
okay
please draw
what air is that's the the question
okay it says an object is not what i can
see and touch
uh that well that was my definition so
he's saying an object is not what i can
see and touch wow i guess i learned
something new today yeah i guess he did
i whether he learned it or not i don't
know how is one ever
how is one to ever proof
something exists if he cannot see or
touch it
and you can see how they confuse the
word object with the word exist they
make those two synonyms they think an
object is that which you can see and
touch in existence is that which you can
see and touch so for them the word
object the word exists are synonyms and
that's been the case with 99 of humanity
today
okay so
uh in that sense they all have the same
notion that an object is that which you
can see and touch
okay and so he says how do you prove it
he thinks he's going to prove existence
you know you prove the existence of the
chair by touching it and sitting on it
and seeing it
and so again is the chair that's on the
other side of the planet does is that an
object first of all because you can't
see or touch it so i guess it's not a an
object so what is the japanese or the
australian sitting on um
i mean
is he sitting on an object
does that object exist and you're saying
i gotta see it and touch it but
otherwise it doesn't exist
so again their notion is is their little
world inside their tiny minds okay
it's a it's this little tiny world that
they have there and their whole world
just goes in that area
uh
okay i thought maybe someone cut me off
there
uh so they have this small world and
it's just whatever they can see and
touch
they cannot go beyond that they they did
you know they receive a call maybe on
their cell phone from japan
where's that coming from does that
person exist i mean you can't see him or
touch him
does that person exist is that person an
object
and
they don't have the mental capacity to
understand what i just said
they don't realize that there's someone
who called them on the phone who do they
think called them
uh god i mean i don't know
so you want us to accept all these
concepts without proof see again they
they harp on proof on evidence
they they want they don't want an
explanation they don't want a mechanism
what they want is for you to convince
them
that's the issue okay and if they can't
see or touch it they say i'm not
convinced
and so you can't see or test the person
who's on the other side of the planet
who's calling you so that person is not
an
object that person doesn't exist
okay
and so take your word for their
existence and again uh they mix the word
object with exist that's one and then
exists does not see your touch
okay so these are the uh gross errors in
logic if you can call what they do logic
at all uh
rationality
uh
and they just mix these things up object
with exists and
and why because they don't have
definitions that's the issue they don't
work off of scientific definitions they
use the definitions of ordinary speech
and in their tiny little minds that's
what they live with that's all they've
got so when they come into the
scientific world they bring those
definitions of common speech of everyday
speech and they think they're making
sense they say oh yeah object that which
i can see and touch
exists that which i can see and touch
and what about the objects that you
can't see or touch does the air exist i
mean you can't see it
you know you say you touch it but what
did you touch maybe touch the ghost i
don't know
okay
okay so these are conclusion flat
earthers misunderstand basic physics
they are very very ignorant people okay
no apologies there whatsoever okay
they harp on belief rather than on
explanation they don't want an
explanation they don't want you to
explain a mechanism
what they want is for them to
for you to convince them they want you
to harp on their belief system
and they they withhold belief because
they say you haven't proven
that there's some that there's air
you know because i can't see it and you
haven't proven that that australian is
sitting on a chair because i can't see
or touch it so that chair doesn't exist
and that's the guy that called you just
now you know he was sitting down calling
you but he doesn't believe that because
he doesn't see it he doesn't he can't
touch it so he says
that australian doesn't exist
and he's not an object either and but
someone called him you know who knows
okay
maybe it was his mother from new york he
doesn't see or touch her either but
he says oh ma how are you
who are you talking to i mean
you can't see your toucher
okay uh so what what will
flat earthers have to do well they have
to answer the cause of inertia okay
and um
these are some of the things that they
can address one what causes the air to
go to the back of the car okay what
causes the air to go back uh what thing
is in contact with the air molecules
draw it i want you to draw whatever's in
contact with the air molecules and again
mox principle
newton's bucket
says that something outside the earth is
pulling on every atom
on earth
and when the
uh skater rotates her arms are pulled
outwards tell me why what's pulling on
her arms
okay or maybe pushing i don't know maybe
you want to do push gravity or push into
a chef fine
what pushes it and pulls uh or pulls the
pen to the floor okay we have the pen or
pencil right let go of it
again i'm not pushing it downwards it
just falls why does it go down why does
it go upwards that's the question okay
why does it i wanted to go someday i
wanted to go to the ceiling
okay and what brings two magnets
together okay
you're saying there's nothing here then
you're doing black magic that's what
you're doing
because you're saying that this comes
together with that one
uh for no reason whatsoever
and it always does the same thing you
know it just comes together in fact if i
hold it lightly you can see how it just
goes by itself
and you're saying there's nothing here
simply because you can't see or touch it
okay that's the issue for you because
for you an object is that which can be
seen or touched in existence is that
which you can see or touch
and again i can show you that you can't
see or touch the person on the other
side of the planet meaning that that's a
irrational definition an irrational
notion that you have of what an object
is and what existence means okay
action not a distance any action at a
distance black magic
like everything from mathematical
physics you know they talk about
entanglement they talk about gravity
they can't explain it why because they
never identify the physical object that
we cannot see or touch
so you cannot use the seed touch
criteria that's the issue okay and uh if
you're using concepts such as field or
mass or
what is it density you know any of those
you're doing black magic because you
cannot say density does this and uh i
don't know mass does that you can't use
the concepts
as physical objects to explain a
mechanism okay so we got that
and what you need to do is identify the
invisible intangible
mediators that mother nature uses to do
her daily work mother nature father
universe god the devil whoever you pray
to i don't care
i need to find out what those physical
objects are those invisible intangible
objects that they use every day to do
gravity density
mass whatever you want to call it okay
so that's that's the homework okay if
you can do it
and uh final note file says uh let me
put over here says uh first telling
why the concept of visualization is so
important and then immediately after
discarding einstein's theories
completely
laugh out loud
well uh
i'm not sure he's laughing at himself
because he's laughing out of ignorance
because einstein never had any
visualization whatsoever
okay so let's get that straight
all about einstein's nonsense was all
abstract math
never he had did he have a mechanism a
physical mechanism for how the universe
works to say that space-time
warpage you know is what causes gravity
that's an absolute poppycock okay
so uh you can't say that he
illustrated anything that he made you
know uh something visual for us
absolutely not in fact uh to this day
most mathematicians will tell you that
they have no answer to that when you say
well how about space time this canvas
now you're taking the analogy too
literally
that's that's the answer you get
in other words they don't have to this
day a physical mechanism objects things
that explain how gravity works how
inertia works how mass works
they don't have that
all they have is mathematical equation
mathematical concepts that's it
okay so we got that
uh now you know what your homework is
okay figure out inertia figure out why
that girl
spins and her arms come outwards that's
what you got to figure out and uh i
would advise that you look up uh mach
principle
newton's bucket so that you become
familiarized with the invisible
intangible things that are in contact
with our bodies from outside the earth
let's move on to uh
numena what are pneumonia well it comes
in very handy today because that's
exactly what flat earthers don't believe
in okay in fact i would say 99 of
humanity doesn't believe in numina okay
this word was invented by immanuel kant
and
maybe
and what he said is that
some objects we can touch and see
but others we can't
they are objects you can say of the mind
okay we can imagine them we can
visualize them maybe
and
they're only in in the mind okay and so
uh you got to think about that because
people say well if it's in the mind it
doesn't exist
well not necessarily see because
you can make an assumption about an
object that you cannot see or touch
which is what newman is all about and
you can say well you know what if
there's an object you cannot see and
touch that mediates gravity that
mediates inertia that mediates mass okay
so that's the issue so let's go with mr
kant can't see what he says and
these are summaries of essentially of
his
main points he says newman are objects
of the understanding okay that can be
given an
intuition
although not to
not to to
sensible intuition in other words
sensible meaning
senses okay so
they're given to intuition but not to
the senses and the comment that you'll
find in the uh
stanford encyclopedia is clearly we do
not
recognize
any pneumonia since to cognize an object
for us requires intuition and our
intuition is sensible not intellectual
okay so they're saying that
or at least whoever wrote that piece
says that
they cannot imagine
even something like newman existing
because
intuition doesn't work through the mind
intuition works through our senses
and phenomena are related to senses
and numera are not and so that
like automatically disqualifies them
that's more or less the
the argument there
okay um
that's one take on that
what did mr khan conclude
um essentially this is a summary again
of his conclusions right
we know the newman now word world to
exist because human sensibility is
merely receptive in other words when you
touch when you see okay that's receptive
that depends on the individual on the
observer right however it is not itself
sensible the new men are right and must
therefore remain otherwise unknowable to
us
so they're talking about the unknowable
uh pneumonia
right now we're looking at two things on
the one hand they're saying look
phenomenon is that which you can see and
touch whereas pneumonia you can't see or
touch it's there or at least you posit
that it's there
but it's unknowable and again they use
this word no which no one ever defines
in other words you don't believe in it
because that's what knowledge is belief
okay so this is where the problem comes
in they introduce words or situations
that have no
bearing on the issue before us
are there objects that we cannot see or
touch are there phenomena that we cannot
see or touch that's the question
okay so
here we have
let me get this one out of here
um
the definition that we find at the
wikipedia after this is after i mean
you're talking about i think 1781 that
um
kant wrote the critique of reason okay
and here's uh
here's what we've come up with after 200
300 years
since that book lumenon object or event
that exists
big problem there we can say that object
can exist we cannot say that an event
exists a happening exists an occurrence
existing
okay what do you mean when you say that
an event exists so big problem there
already but it says object or event that
exists independently of human sense and
or perception you cannot
expect to sense this with your eyes with
your hands with your ears with your
smell nothing
you can't sense
these objects known as pneumonia
plural pneumonia
singular
but you look at the word object it says
object or event that exists
independently of human sense right
or perception
object a thing observed
of course if you're going to define
object as a thing observed and again
that's a definition that the wikipedia
addre
links right
if if
a thing is that which can be observed
then that automatically rules out
pneumatic because you cannot observe it
by definition
so we have a contradiction already there
okay
and
continues there it says objects may not
have real existence independent of the
subject who observes
again introducing the observer the
the person who's gonna the judge
so to speak right
at issues whether objects can exist
independently of their properties and
again they put the word exist always
with the word object okay it's like they
cannot separate the word object from
word exist
okay and by that i mean that if object
is that which is observed meaning c
touch
exists is also by default c touch
that's what it amounts to
you look at the word event because as
object or event that exists you look at
the word event and and it says it's a
phenomenon
so events are phenomena
you look at phenomena as an observable
event
typical of mathematicians they never
learn how to define key words so they go
around in circles you never know what
they say because they never define their
language the key language with which
they have to make their case
so we haven't learned anything from
these people at the wikipedia and that
is essentially a summary of what people
know out there the
the state of the art knowledge
of uh the scientific world
in many ways it's condensed in there
okay maybe not in fine detail but it
gives you an overview and this is where
they're at they haven't defined any key
word they don't know what exist means
they don't know what an object is they
don't know what distance or location is
they don't have a definition for any of
these words that
form the foundations of physics
okay
what do the mathematicians consider
numina okay the
mathematicians as i call them okay
uh this imagine mathematics they say
essentially right new men are
unobservables
you cannot observe
and
of course mathematics does not
vouch too much they don't care too much
about stuff that they cannot observe
means c touch
and so
they think that this stuff belongs only
to philosophy
so if there are objects that we cannot
see or touch out there
we can't see the air right you can't see
the chair
the australians sitting on the other
side of the
uh planet or or touch it right
so
we have a problem first of all is it an
object does it exist
and mathematicians don't go that far
they just worry about their little world
just like the flat earthers so we don't
have an answer to those questions
obviously the definition the seed touch
definition the criteria used to define
objects and existence it's irrational
you can't use those definitions in
science we need to redefine all those
words because they do form the
foundations of physics
okay so um
this is my take on that you have to
define these two words object and exist
what is an object that would just shape
what is exist well it has to have
location what is location the set of
distances to all other objects
okay so in order to exist we have to
have all other objects in the universe
that's essentially it see if god wants
to exist
god first has to be an object a thing
and there you can see that
uh looks like
god is a thing because god has shaped us
i see a shape there okay so uh
god seems to
meet the criteria of the definition of
object so god is a thing but that's not
enough to exist if god wants to exist
also has to have distance with respect
to all objects that exist
okay
there's got to be a straight line of
direction from god to me i don't care
where he wishes what dimension he wishes
to hide in so uh yeah that's the
definition that definition we can take
to the bank okay we can use that
definition and if an object does that
which has shape and exists means an
object that has location now we can
apply these definitions consistently to
talk rationally not like the flat
earthers and all other
people out there like the mathematicians
who go out there and start talking about
object that exists without defining
those two words and they use those words
constantly all of these people okay they
use them constantly but they never
defined them all you find in the
dictionary or in the case of exists are
synonyms and in the case of object the
main one is see and touch that's what
all these people
believe in or that's the notion that
they have in the back of their brains
okay so here let me give you an object
that
is invisible and intangible okay
but it is an object and it's my uh
electromagnetic role electromagnetic
rope is a pneumation right
it's part of the pneumonia that's out
there okay
the mediator of light and gravity is
invisible and intangible it's a dna-like
pair of twine threads
we call it the electromagnetic rope
because it has the architecture of a
rope not because it's a rope that you
buy at the hardware store but because it
has the
dna like uh
architecture that's the only reason we
call it a rope okay so people go bonkers
over the word rope and they say what do
you mean it's a robe what is it made out
of and then they start with all the
nonsense question no it's uh whatever's
out there has a architecture of a rope
meaning a pair of twine threads it
torques when it torques we call that
light
okay and uh yeah because we can't see it
or touch it we have no chance of
discovering it through an experiment
okay all we can do is visualize it
and
that's why it's a pneumatic because it's
a
product of the mind you make an
assumption it's not that you believe in
it it's it's an assumption that's what
it's called in science okay make an
assumption say
let us assume
that all atoms are physically
interconnected by the electromagnetic
rope a pneumaton
something that you cannot see or touch
that's the starting point it's an
assumption that's known as an assumption
you posit it
okay so now with that you can say okay
what is light well if the atom expands
and contracts it torques the rope and
the torsion that propagates along the
rope which is really the torsion
in-situ
torsion of that
rope
that's what we call light so we have the
object which is the rope and what it
does the torsion
and together we call that light
that's how simple it is okay that's the
proposal
do you believe it we don't care if you
do or not uh belief is for churches okay
signs we explain so that you understand
once you understand we draw the line
you cross the line you're into religion
you're talking about belief whether you
uh
uh pray to it or whatever that's that's
your personal business it doesn't
concern science at all
okay what are some of the rejoinders
that people raise against pneumonia such
as
the electromagnetic rope okay here it is
uh i can't save them
that's irrelevant uh how can i detect
them that's irrational
why is it irrelevant and irrational
because pneumonia that which you can't
see or touch
so why ask a question about see touch
when that's not the definition of
pneumonia which is an object that you
cannot see or touch
and uh always i asked the same question
there why didn't you ask that question
to quantum mechanics
i mean can you see the particles that
they're talking about when they say oh
the photon
the electron
the muon
pion and all these other
particles of gluon right did you ever
ask them can you see or touch them
well then they're not particles because
i can't see your time they're not
objects
right
but see people accept them they say
particles and people say okay i
understand that's a little ball
and nobody
takes it any further than that they
accept quantum mechanics blindly
okay they say yeah okay it's a little
ball there that does this and then we
call this one a photon the other one is
the
electron ball the other one's the gluon
ball they're all balls
okay and you never ask them can you see
or touch them
okay so why do you ask me if i can see
or touch
the rope if i'm saying it's a pneumaton
you can't see or touch it by definition
but you ask the question
and you don't ask the question in
quantum mechanics
can you see here touch space time okay
again uh take that to relativity and so
on okay so a thing is that which has
shape not that which you can see or
touch so
end of story there how can it have shape
if you can't see or touch it
uh how do you know it has shape and the
answer is congratulations you just made
the idiot honor roll
can you prove their existence
numina right
proof is religion proof is in the
pudding proof is what uh alcohol has
okay
religion uh that's what uh proof has to
do with it's opinion believe truth
persuade convince convert recruit
knowledge
evidence all that has to do with
religion we don't we don't try to
convert people we don't try to prove we
don't try to present evidence
okay you can if you want but that's not
science science is mechanism
in phys as it relates to physics
and uh the electromagnetic rope
essentially explains light and gravity
that's that's the purpose of
positing that there is an
electromagnetic rope but a pneumonia out
there neumann on okay that we're gonna
use to explain a mechanism so that you
understand it now so that you believe it
okay so that you can try to visualize
and say well is this how the universe
works okay so it's food for thought okay
and people say well i don't believe in
it i don't care that's irrelevant if you
believe or not okay
okay so uh that's new enough for you
okay
and uh hopefully we move on to another
subject which is knowledge a lot of
people have uh questions regarding
knowledge okay so let's go on with that
and uh where do we start here well we
start with a person who
essentially
criticize the notion that knowledge is
something that you have to prove to
someone else
okay because
you know knowledge essentially by the
greeks was defined as belief no
difference between knowledge and belief
if anything knowledge
is
deeper belief
you believe more strongly
when you have knowledge than when you
just believe that's more or less it but
it all goes down to you
knowledge is something you have yourself
because belief is what you have yourself
and there are different degrees and we
say that a hundred percent belief is
knowledge more or less that's that's the
notion
and
but i'm saying that uh now there's
something that you must prove to someone
else
that's the only way that
we can really use that in a way that
we've been using at all these years you
know how do you prove knowledge in
college well you go up there and you try
to pursue the teachers that you know
that means you're going to try to
convince them that you know of your
beliefs
okay that you know what you studied
or you think you know at least
okay so this file says no you don't
prove knowledge to someone else
so he says the following says knowledge
include
proving something to others
knowledge exists as soon as it is
discovered
not as soon as is proven to enough
people
i see
well um
let's first put my definition so that
you can see
why he uh where he comes with all this
with his version his rejoinder
essentially okay and this is it despite
deriving from the word knowledge
uh science has nothing to do with
knowledge okay so the word seeded that's
where science comes from has to do with
the word no
or knowledge and uh that's where the
word science comes from that's the
etymology but we don't care our
forefathers screwed it up from the start
when they uh identified science with
knowledge okay so we're criticizing that
we're
negating that and we're saying that no
the
science has nothing to do with knowledge
science has to do with explanations
okay
and
now this this is our definition now is
predicting to others right the result of
an experiment without error
that's what all these people have been
saying all these years
that's what we're arguing here we're
saying that knowledge is what you prove
to others
okay
and um not even god omniscient god
can predict the
result of an experiment without error
if if he can without error that means
the future already exists
uh the block universe you know general
relativities block universe
uh and you can take it all the way to
the days of augustine saint augustine
and you'll find that you know they've
always had this notion of the block
universe that god sees the future the
past the present everything at the same
time so that's the blocked universe but
if that's the case then you if you
believe in that if you accept that you
accept that um
assumption um
well that reduces you to a cartoon
character that means that you're you're
just
following footsteps that you cannot
avoid because everything the future's
already been determined
okay so if the future is already there
and you're then all you're doing is just
walking in footsteps and you're no
different than bugs bunny in a cartoon
character
so hopefully you don't accept that as an
assumption or as a belief
that the future already exists
okay it's there it's already made up
because if you do you
have no um
free will meaning that
you know whatever crime you command
you're off the hook because you know you
had no choice you you were forced to do
it because that was the script
you you just followed script whether you
knew it or not you know had to follow
script it was already the cards were
already thrown
so that's the problem with accepting
[Music]
that we know
okay and no again means uh like it says
they're predicting to others the result
of an experiment without error
and you cannot predict uh and some
people say well yeah i can predict that
yeah let me get this out of here
uh i can predict that um
this pencil is gonna fall to the floor
downwards
uh 100 of the
time and you know i can play a joke on
you and put a couple magnets and have it
stand in the air
or maybe i don't even need that maybe an
asteroid comes and destroys the earth
and your prediction didn't come true
of course i can't collect my bet
or maybe it kills you alone and you
didn't get to you know prove your
experiment
so we cannot
be uh we cannot prove
without air anything in the future
that's the issue okay anything go wrong
usually it doesn't or sometimes it does
murphy's law right but
you cannot predict everything in the
future 100 that's the point so there is
no such thing as knowledge but that is
the definition of the word knowledge
that we can use consistently
and you say well is that true
okay so let's go through it let's uh
first look what the greeks said about
knowledge and i covered that uh the
other day
knowledge a true judgment with an
account in other words justify true
belief that came from the mouth i guess
of socrates and
uh plato uh wrote it in his book
theaters adidas
but he put the words
he gave credit to socrates okay
so uh yeah knowledge is just
justified true belief that means you
you're justified yourself right in
believing it that's all that knowledge
is and again i call it deep
belief it's a
knowledge is just a deeper belief than
regular belief you could say that's all
it is but it all dies with you
okay according to the greeks and
according to the notions that we have
today and i'm trying to change that i'm
saying look we don't have the any use
for the word knowledge and science but
if you're going to use it this is what
you always have meant by it the only way
you can use it consistently and that is
predicting without error the results of
an experiment
i mean if you're if you go to college
and uh you're in front of the
board they're trying to get your degree
you
you are going to try to prove your
knowledge to them how do you prove it
you know uh well you run an experiment
and you say this what's going to happen
you know i put the
uh
red liquid with a green liquid and it
turns uh blue
you can say something and then you
explain why maybe
and then
so now you have an explanation you have
you you predicted the results of the
experiment and you were about to run
that's how you prove it can you prove
the past
well let's find out let's look at some
of the
uh uses that we have with the word no or
the word knowledge and we're going to
see
why it's become so complex to understand
the word knowledge and why people have
irrational notions of what knowledge is
let's go with the first one okay here
do you know that
for example the pythagorean
theorem
that's c squared equals a squared plus b
squared
do you know that the number pi for sure
that circumference divided by diameter
is equal to 314 et cetera et cetera et
cetera uh force equals mass times
acceleration e equals mc squared
you say well i know this
you do do you
so what did you just say what do you
mean you know it what is the definition
of knowledge if you're going to say that
you know that this
that you know this
so i need a definition of the word
knowledge before you can say i know that
this is true or whatever that i know
this okay maybe you memorized it
did you run an experiment how did how do
you know this
okay so that's the first one did you
just memorize it in high school and you
say i know it meaning you can recite it
so i need a definition of the word no if
you're going to use it to say that you
know any of these things or any other
equation or whatever you find out there
okay that's the first one
let's go with the second one here
um
do you know history
do you know that alex the great slept
with epheston do you know that uh caesar
across the rubicon in uh 49 bc do you
know that hitler attacked france in 1940
were you there i mean
and even if you were there
this doesn't it's worthless because
are you going to prove it to me how are
you going to prove for example that neil
armstrong
right stepped on the moon in 1969 today
how are you going to prove that
you're going to run an experiment and
say look this is the foot of neil
armstrong and this is how he stepped on
the moon in 1969
is that how it's done is that how you
prove
that man stop down the moon for the
first time
so you can see we're going to use the
word no in different context here and
what i need is a definition of the word
no
that
includes all of them
if you cannot define it with all of them
then we got a problem
because you you cannot say that you know
that neil armstrong stepped on the moon
in 1969 that you know that uh
circumference divided by diameters pie
you can't say you know
because you haven't defined the word no
i don't know what you mean when you say
no
okay so that's going to be the issue
here
okay here's another context okay do you
know that you have a head
do you
know that you cut your hand you're
bleeding you that you have two legs and
that there's a wall
to your right do you know this
say yeah i know
well what does it mean
how are you going to define the word no
in such a way to encompass all of these
different situations that's the question
before you
okay
let's see if we get it right
here's another one another context okay
do you know that god exists
how about time has warped you know uh uh
space time
time has worked
do you know that time has worked
or do you believe it
uh do you know that a particle can be at
two places at once
do you know that black holes
suck
do you know
do you know
[Music]
yeah you gotta define the word no if
you're gonna be using it in a scientific
context because people wanna include the
word knowledge
no into science okay fine define it in
such a way that we can use it
consistently in all
of these contexts okay
if you're going to eliminate one of the
context you got to justify why because
you know
i know history i know that napoleon went
to waterloo in 1815 and he said well
that's not knowledge okay then why isn't
it now let's do we believe that we
but we don't believe um
uh uh we we don't believe that um
circumference divided by diameter
is pi
314
that's not a belief that's that's a
knowledge
and you say well i can apply it in
technology i can do stuff with circles
and diameters and so on
well socrates already
killed that one uh
three thousand years ago okay so just
check uh the
theaters and you'll find that uh he
already tore that notion down okay so
you got to read it okay
okay how about this one uh do you know
that uh spoon will fall when i get let
go of it
do you know this
and you say well i do know you know
here's a uh
here spoon okay little spoon we let go
of it it falls down
and it turns out that you know
i had air pushing from below just when
you threw it
and so you did not know that it was
going to fall because standing in the
air
oh you tricked me irrelevant
irrelevant because the issue was whether
you knew whether you could predict
the result of that experiment without
air okay
do you know that the sun will rise
tomorrow do you know that there will be
an eclipse in a minute there in that
situation where the
moon is covering the sun
do you know
what do you mean you know
what's the definition of knowledge
that's the question do you know that the
plane will crash you know some things we
say well that's gonna happen
and maybe something else happens and it
doesn't happen with the way you thought
it was gonna your knowledge was not
complete for some reason
okay how about this one
do you know johnny
uh do you know where he lives
uh do you know who your boss is do you
know your love from your right hand
right
um
like i said in other languages
like spanish and german
they have different words for for these
types of knowledge when you know johnny
uh
they don't use the word no they have a
different word for those almost in every
language the only one that i know is
english that doesn't
have a word for those which is kind of
it's it's like acquaintance more than
knowledge okay
but anyways uh again you got to define
the word knowledge in order for us to
use it all these different contexts okay
here's another
uh knowledge
and here we're gonna be talking about
theories okay here it is do you know
what causes gravity
is that the same thing as knowing that
napoleon went to waterloo
i mean are we talking about the same
type of knowledge here
uh
do you know that a magnet attracts
another is this knowledge
or
or
or are you supposed to provide a
mechanism an explanation of physical
interpretation
do you know what electricity is do you
know what prevents the earth from flying
out of the solar system
these are the
questions that you've got to answer
if you're going to define the word
knowledge and included within science
and i'm saying the only one that is
applicable
and again there's no knowledge but the
only one that would be applicable is
the notion that we have where you prove
to someone else your knowledge
if you're on an island all by yourself
and you cut your arm you say well i know
i cut my arm i see it i feel it i know i
cut my heart i know i have a head
i know i have two arms i know i have two
legs you know you you know this
but see what whatever knowledge you have
yourself it's just a belief what's the
difference between belief and knowledge
if you're the only person on in the
universe
now there's just something you're gonna
show someone else you're gonna say let
me show you that i know
because otherwise you just have a belief
and if you're gonna say look i i cut
myself i know i cut myself but i'm on
the other side of the world and i can't
see you or whatever
you know uh what am i supposed to say uh
that you believe until you prove it to
me
so again the issue is defining the word
knowledge in such a way that you can use
it consistently in science if you're
going to bring that word into science
such that you can use it in all these
contexts if you reject any of the
context you have to also justify why
because that's how it's used in ordinary
speech in all these contexts
we got that
okay let's move on to our science critic
okay and now this fellow
uh
he thinks that an explanation is just a
description
and so many people believe that in fact
all of mathematical physics
on the one hand they say well it's not a
description it's not a an explanation
then they say exactly the opposite they
say yeah the explanation in the end is
just a bunch of descriptions
so they haven't figured out the
difference between an explanation and a
description this is the problem
okay so let me turn this fella loose so
that you know what the issue is
here goes pay attention
the issue to be addressed in this
rebuttal is
is a description the same as an
explanation
now another thing that i take issue with
that he said is science only explains it
doesn't describe
well i'm sorry
but a description can be an explanation
the only real difference between a
description and an explanation is a
description is describing how something
is an explanation is answering a
question so if you ask the question of
why is the sky blue you'll receive an
explanation of rayleigh scattering
but really scattering is a description
of what's happening there and that
description explains
why the sky is blue
okay
so
he gives this example rarely
scattering
and so if you look it up you'll find
same thing that i found and i found it
in
hyperphysics here it is
and here you can see the difference
between a description and explanation
which this fellow did not understand i
mean on the one hand he says look one
answer is a question
but it's like
he didn't listen to what he was saying
okay so here's this is description
and this comes all out of the same place
rayleigh scattering uh refers to the
scattering of light off of the molecules
of the air
and can be extended to scattering from
particles up to about a tenth of the
wavelength of the light
so far all we have is an ex
a description we have no idea why the
sky is blue so far
okay all they're saying is that
molecules scatter light
that's a description right now we have
no explanation of anything
now comes the explanation of the
mechanism of the cause okay of what of
why the sky is blue in it is rayleigh
scattering off the molecules of the ear
which give us the blue sky
and now you can go into more detail and
say look this is the explanation of why
what causes the sky to be blue
but you cannot go with the first
paragraph there and say oh that
explained it explains why the sky is
blue
so you can see a little bit of a
difference here and this is just in
general terms so you can see the
difference between a description and an
explanation like he says an explanation
answers a question a description does
not
but he doesn't understand what he said
okay this is this is
so you wonder about his mental state or
what is going through that you know
through between his ears he's got very
little to block the information that's
going through there anyways here uh let
me give you an example okay another
example this is
uh referring to the rope okay here it is
here's a picture or a movie right
of two atoms bound by the rope
so far you have no explanation well so
far all we've got is a description it's
an illustration and you can say okay two
atoms they're apparently expanding and
contracting and there's a rope between
them that's a description so far unless
i give you some background talking
behind and tell you what you're staring
at
what this is all about
you won't have any idea that that rope
torquing there is supposed to represent
light okay
now uh you know i constantly say that
you need to make movies of your physical
interpretations okay
because a picture if a picture's worth
a thousand words
a movie is worth a million words okay so
so keep that in mind but the issue here
is very simple is um
i'm uh
on the one hand giving you a description
of the mechanism but unless i tell you
what i'm trying to explain what i'm
trying to answer
you will not have an explanation all you
will have is a description okay
mathematics can only describe an
equation is only a description of a
dynamic
situation
that's all
you know an equation is so all you have
is a description if you want an
explanation you won't find it in
mathematics
you'll have to go to physics
and that's where the problem is because
the mathematicians have united or
extrapolated mathematical concepts into
physics and purport to explain how this
universe works
by using mathematics by using
equations but again all that is a
description both of them are housed
how something
works
meaning
how it works in the sense of how fast it
works how much time that's different
than saying how it works like what is
the mechanism those are two different
house
it's uh like if you hear you're talking
about the why and by why i don't mean
purpose and reason i mean cause and
mechanism so in that sense the y is not
a how
okay and so those housing wires they get
them mixed up constantly that's that's
the big problem so anyways uh no an
explanation is not a description and
description is not an explanation
uh explanation answers a question
okay so keep that in mind that is the
answer to his
rebuttal okay
and so let's move on here to some of the
questions that people asked since last
time
and first guy says when we agree when we
agree black holes do not exist
we apparently do not agree on the
explanation for why they do not exist
it is all imaginary that's why they
don't exist so he's saying that
non-existence is equal to
uh or identified with imaginary there is
no need to proof
meaning prove
an object exists yeah there is no need
you just follow the definition because
we can see and touch it
so again all these people these flat
earthers they believe that um
existence has to do with c and touch
that's what it means in their tiny
brains because that's what they have in
ordinary speech and every day in their
everyday world
but when they come into science they
want to bring that irrational definition
over and that's when we stop them we say
no no you can't use that definition here
that definition is an irrational
definition that can be used over there
in ordinary speech you can say love
exists over there if you want in physics
you cannot say that love exists you can
say energy exists over there in ordinary
speech you cannot say energy exists
in physics
okay in science okay
for that you need to define the word
exist very very precisely because
physics is the science of existence okay
so keep that in mind
okay and says objects do not need any
location for how then can objects exist
that i myself cannot see or touch
well you cannot see the air i mean does
the air exist
again all these people
they have tiny brains they really have
they don't have the ability to think
these things over
do does the chair of that australian on
the other side of the planet does that
chair exist
is that an object is he what is he
sitting on
when he calls you
on the phone
he calling you on the phone you're
talking to someone he says i'm sitting
on a chair well i don't believe a chair
is an object your your chair because i
can't see or touch it and i don't think
it exists because i can't see it or
touch it
is that a rational statement
this is what this fellow is saying
not every object i know to exist uh has
a fixed location within my observational
distances so he he's got this tiny world
that only that like uh this other person
said anything that he can see or touch
that's all that's his entire world
anything beyond that he says i don't
believe i don't accept
but he doesn't realize that if he does
that he is he's essentially saying that
the chair that the australian is sitting
on is not a physical object and it
doesn't exist because he cannot see or
touch it because it's outside his what
observational distance
that's how irrational this individual is
and so you are the one claiming
invisible objects even exist not flat
earthers correct
and hopefully
and the burden of proof is on you no
this has nothing to do with proof it's
got to do with making an assumption
about numina you know it's uh
are there objects that we can't see or
touch
is the air an object is it a thing is it
made out of atoms if not tell me what it
is that you're
sweeping when you move your hand and
what is it a spirit a ghost what are you
breathing
you know something's entering your your
mouth right tell me what okay uh draw it
how are you gonna draw it if you cannot
visualize it if you say well i don't
believe it exists because i can't see it
well i don't know i don't know what to
tell you you got to define the word
exists in such a way that you can use it
consistently
you have to define the word object also
in a way that you can use it
consistently
okay and uh here's another he says could
you explain quantum computers
um
yeah quantum computers is a sales pitch
that's all it is
okay they put the word quantum
to say just to reinforce that they've
proven quantum mechanics that's why they
put the word quantum the only reason
they put the word quantum in there
they say that quantum computers have
some of these features that they drew
from experience
at the accelerators
photon orientation electron span
superposition entanglement
the problem is they've never
verified any of these they they
they don't know what causes entanglement
they don't know the mechanism that
underlies superposition or electron spin
which is not spin by the way it's not a
top spinning they don't know what uh
photon oriented they've never seen a
photon so what are they talking about
photon orientation
so what happens with all these things
they go to the lab
they have the visible part and the
invisible part the pneumonia okay stuff
that they can't see or touch and the
stuff that they cannot see or touch they
infer
they infer that it's there under the
under the particle model
so they give it an explanation under the
particle model that's the issue
and they say we don't understand it
well if you don't understand it how did
you build a computer with it
well they take the effect it's just like
edison thomas edison
invented the bulb right that could be
usable that could be sold out there
a device that a workable device
and he said
he never understood electricity he
didn't know what electricity was
no one to this day no the electric
universe especially doesn't know what
electricity is
so they're they're called electric
universe they don't know what an
electric means
okay so so
if they don't know today certainly uh
good old uh
thomas edison didn't know in those days
he didn't need to know he just needed to
know
that he tried one thing after another
until he got it right in fact he says
i have not failed
i just found ten thousand ways that
don't work
that's how he did it he just tried one
thing after another until he got it
right he doesn't have to understand any
of that and this is no different
one of them people no there's not a
single quantum
individual on planet earth quantum
so-called physicist mathematician that
can tell you photon orientation they
have no idea because they've never seen
a photon they have no idea they infer
that there's a little particle that's
got some kind of orientation they don't
know what electron spin is they don't
know what spin is they can't define it
they don't know how superposition works
they say they don't understand it they
have no idea how entanglement works they
just say it does
and they use that it does to do
technology
so they're using some of these features
which they do not understand
and that's where the theory should
vibrate
a theory is an explanation of the
mechanism if you do not know the
mechanism the fact that you can use it
to do technology does not allow you to
use the word quantum meaning
you know in the name like quantum
computers meaning or implying that your
theory is correct
the theory is not correct because they
cannot explain it and a theory is an
explanation not a description
and right now they have descriptions no
explanation so they have no explanation
for any of these so the word quantum is
put in there just to fool you into
believing that
their theory is correct that quantum has
been proven and it's a done deal that's
the only purpose of putting the word
quantum
and the answer is no the quantum has not
been proven
especially the physical interpretations
that's why to this day they all say
every single mathematician out there
says we don't understand
how quantum works
if they don't understand the mechanism
they don't have a theory
quantum is not a theory it's a
description
okay and it's a description based on the
particle hypothesis
discrete particle hypothesis which is
irrational to begin with because you
cannot explain
any phenomenon with quant with particles
assuming they were particles which they
ain't
the particles of classical uh mechanics
died at the end of the
19th century what came after
was quantum
mechanics not any left behind
what is it
classical mechanics
so so the particles are not particles
though so-called particle is a number
that's what it is okay so until you
understand all that you haven't
understood anything about quantum
mechanics quantum mechanics only deals
with numbers it's a description it has
no explanation no mechanism so they
don't know how it works but they know it
does work under it's it's like um you
know electricity you get zapped by
electricity right and it turns out in
the light you don't know what it is but
it turns on the light that's good enough
for you you can use it to do something
some technology and you say i'm going to
use electricity
so what's your theory of electricity do
you know what electricity is oh i don't
know but it works and i can make this
device with it i can turn on lights with
it
so that's the situation with quantum
computers
they don't understand any of the
theories they don't have an explanation
of physical interpretation they just
know the effects and they use the
effects to make technology and they call
it quantum and people are fooled into
believing that quantum has been proven
and the theories are correct et cetera
et cetera
okay here uh
[Music]
another fella asks he says belief is a
consequence of owning a thing and
pursuing an understanding of it in order
to control the destiny of its ownership
and the destiny of yourself as its owner
belief all by itself is insubstantial
and of no consequence it transfers
responsibility to whoever sold you this
belief
okay
hence you are at the mercy of whoever is
its author belief is for children not
for adults
i like that one
yeah belief is for children we don't
care about uh belief in science okay
so um any person talks about knowledge
or belief other i guess they're children
we can say that right in science we make
assumptions we explain mechanisms as it
relates to physics and
and then you can believe whatever you
want okay
belief is the
part that belongs to religion it doesn't
belong to science at all that includes
knowledge which is just
more
profound more deeper belief that's all
knowledge is
okay another foul says we know something
is true if it is in accordance with
measurable reality
measurable reality deciding whether a
statement is true involves memory
yeah but it's just your opinion you know
what uh what is true
it's true to you is god true
well ask out there and you'll find a lot
of people who say that it's true that
god is true and another person will say
that god is not true
so who's right i mean
you know
does it involve memory i don't know if
it involves memory i'm not i'm i'm
saying it's irrelevant
determining one is false relies on
reasoning and problem solving
processes such as the scientific method
now uh
science doesn't deal with falsehoods or
with true
truth at all
science doesn't care about true or false
true or false are always opinions okay
and you say well you know what if uh
we don't have facts out there we don't
have truths out there facts and truths
are what mother nature knows father
universe god whoever you believe in but
you know they they know exactly what
happened how the universe works
but they've got all that information
locked up in their cabinet
you can't interview mother nature and
say well am i correct is my truth
the same as your truth we have no way of
verifying that of confirming that
so all we end up with is believing in
certain facts and this guy believes in
this fact the other guy believes in
another fact
that's all we have is again uh beliefs
and the way we do in sex we don't care
about beliefs we say let us assume
okay so we make assumptions so that the
person can follow our dissertation we
build our theory on the assumption that
we made that's the way it works in
science
okay here's uh
he says
bill have you ever seen the ropes
a person who doesn't understand what
noom and i are okay
no
objects are not that which you can see
or touch have you ever seen the air
uh so you know i mean uh is that does
that mean there's no such thing as air
out there because you have never seen
the air
you know again it's all these people who
are bent on talking about c touch
objects
not see or touch existence
also not see your touch
electromagnetic ropes are invisible and
intangible object is that which has
shape electromagnetic ropes have shape
we're done
we're talking about an interconnected
universe okay
that's an assumption we say let us
assume
that all atoms in the universe are
interconnected now that we made the
assumption you take the assumption at
face value to understand the theory now
we move on to the theory and explain the
mechanism the physical interpretation we
explain
okay that's what science is about just
objectively so that
you understand it that's the purpose of
science understanding explanation and
understanding
and last question or issue
person says all atoms are interconnected
yeah that's what we're proposing
uh where has this been demonstrated for
us then can you show us
uh it's invisible and intangible he
wants me to show it to them well yeah
here i can show you a mock-up of what
i'm proposing okay
here's a rope
you can think of the
fists as the atoms right and they're
connected by a rope there i showed you
that's what i'm proposing
what part
do you not understand i'm saying that
that's what's out there
we can't see it or touch it but that's
how you would simulate it
so that you understand the theory i'm
proposing
okay
do you believe it but we don't care
we don't care because it has nothing to
do with science if you believe it or not
we're trying to explain to you so that
you understand it
and then you can reach your own
conclusion in private we don't want to
hear your conclusion either okay so just
keep to yourself
you don't have proof of these atomic
interconnections what proof do you want
for invisible intangible entities what
am i supposed to bring for proof
uh the proof is in the pudding they say
all i can show you is the mock-up of
what i propose i'm saying
light would look something like this
like a dna like a twisted rope right
and it torques right there's this
torsion going on
and that's light
that's what i'm saying that's
that's the explanation the theory
do you believe it we don't care
yeah you believe it exists no i don't
believe it it's an assumption it has
nothing to do with belief but these
people harp on belief on prove it to me
bring the evidence show me the invisible
intention
so what am i supposed to do they have
mental problems they don't understand
what we're saying what we're proposing
here we're proposing explanations that's
what it is
okay so how do we do it in science well
here it is
let me put it over here
science we say uh
we begin by making assumptions okay
and uh so
um
we the assumption of uh the assumptions
are known as hypothesis
and
it includes the objects the definitions
that we're going to use
and the statement of the facts
there are no facts facts is what mother
nature knows we can only make a
statement of what we think
happened
or
is out there we can only make a proposal
an assumption
especially about the invisible
intangible stuff out there like you know
that the mediators of gravity light and
magnetism and so on so this is so we
make an assumption
and this is where it starts it's not a
question of belief
it's a question of assumptions
the assumptions are known as hypothesis
and we build there so that you cannot
follow the dissertation we say okay
these are the objects these are the
definitions i'm going to use and this is
the the first few frames of the film i'm
going to give you the starting point the
scene i'm going to paint the scenery
describe it okay so i've got that now on
that i'm going to base my theory and
that's what science is about the theory
okay and so what uh what science does
now it gives you an explanation of
mechanism physics right
of uh how something works for example
gravity or magnetism
you make an assumption and based on that
assumption you give an explanation an
objective explanation so that the person
understands the mechanism has nothing
whatsoever to do with belief
okay
okay with that i'll see you next sunday
and we'll see you then
bye bye